I really wanted to make a career in
devops so on the basis of my experience
and professional certifications that I
got from prelims and I started off for
applying the jobs and I'm glad to show
you that I have joined a new
organization with around 320 percent of
salary height so they offered me the
operation of devops engineer and now I
am doing what I always wanted to do hey
I am Bhaskar currently I am working as a
devops engineer for a product based
company and currently I am living in
Delhi with my family so when I joined
kimchimney in 2021 I decided to pursue
my career in devops engineering and I
knew that along good professional
experience we need some kind of
professional certifications in the same
so luckily I got a call from Simply
learns team and it really helped me to
take that course because the course
structure is really different and they
offer practical Labs so which was really
different out of mailing so I started
learning out those courses and after
completing of those courses I started
sending out messages to other
organizations and over the time I got
eight job offers so I menu what happens
happens for the good so I'm really happy
to be a part of use devops where we are
working on all the cloud native
Technologies so the course content is
really well what I like the most they
provide live examples they provide
practical labs and real world problems
so the content they have decided from
kid to all the way of kubernetes is
really outstanding it really developed
the skills to pursue this field and
apart from this my experience has taught
me one thing that you should never lose
any hope and for that I keep myself
motivated by exploring new places and
also reading motivational books so yeah
what happens happens for the good you
never know when the opportunity knock at
your door so you should be fully
prepared to make out of it
[Music]